let's take it to the next level we got
an antifa uh we got all these antifa
stories going on right now check this
out
milwaukee men mobbed by black lives
matter activists arrested for trying to
defend his home
now this is the narrative that went out
among many conservative
right-leaning and anti-sjw type
reporters
these black lives matter activists show
up in front of this guy's house
they're screaming they literally have a
banner that says black lives matter they
have the big black lives matter fist
and then this guy in his window shows
what looks like a shotgun
of some sort and then he i guess he
pumps it and then he like aims out the
window
at some point after that cops show up
and arrest him and all of these people
start cheering
we now have an official statement from
the police and we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna break all this down
milwaukee police tweeted suspect
arrested for pointing and aiming a long
gun at protesters
they go on to say on monday september
14th
and this is really weird they include
this weird context that's irrelevant to
the crime in question
on monday september 14th 2020 at
approximately 4
25 pm milwaukee police responded to a
residence located at the 3400 block of
north 80th street
regarding a trouble with subject call
for service
the suspect threatened to physically
harm the victim who is his neighbor
while wielding a chainsaw causing the
victim to fear for their safety
the suspect a 56-year-old man from
milwaukee was arrested for disorderly
conduct while armed
okay i'm not sure what that has to do
with the crime in question
now and why they're saying that
why are they bringing that up are they
saying that the guy who held the long
gun is the guy who threatened the dude
with the chainsaw i think that's where
we're going
it's unclear though yeah on tuesday
september 15th at approximately 5
21 a pm officers were dispatched to a
demonstration at the same location
where several individuals protested
outside the suspect's residence
at approximately 8 30 pm the officers
who were monitoring the protest were
notified
by a witness that the suspect was inside
his residence by a window
and that the suspect motioned the long
gun as if he chambered around
and then pointed the gun at the crowd
the video of the incident was
uh uh well subsequently uh i'm sorry
subsequently broadcasted on several
social media
uh social media outlets officers made
contact with the suspect and observed
that he appeared to be intoxicated he
was subsequently arrested for
endangering safety by use of a dangerous
weapon
while under the influence of an
intoxicant disorderly conduct while
armed and bail jumping
the bale jumping one i don't get
criminal charges
will be referred to the milwaukee county
district attorney's office in the
upcoming days the milwaukee police
department continues to support the
rights of those who choose to peacefully
protest
so what do you what do you think because
i i know a lot more about this but i
want to get your guys impression
before we uh before i tell you more
secrets hmm what do you think
so i think that this guy had every right
to take action against people who were
mobbing him i think the police were
ridiculously cowardly to just walk up
and be like
i see our problem we're gonna arrest you
and then the crowd will disperse and the
fact that the crowd cheered the police
uh there's literally f-12 on the back of
one of the people in that picture
and she's then cheering for the police
yeah that is
ideologically inconsistent with what
she's supposed to be out there rioting
yeah these people who claim to hate the
police want to defund the police
called the police and then cheered when
the police did what they wanted oh my
gosh what's f12
it means f of the police yeah okay my
thoughts are
the first paragraph where they said the
dude at a chainsaw and was threatening
his neighbor
makes it look like they're trying to
make the guy look bad right yep for no
reason unrelated just to like be like
okay you're not going to hate this press
release maybe you'll have sympathy
for us yeah and then i wonder if it's a
stand-your-ground state
it is no no it's a castle doctrine state
meaning if someone's on your property
are you allowed to shoot them
no if they're trying to break in okay so
they weren't trying to break and they're
outside on his property yelling at him
and shining
lights and playing live music shining
lights so they were they were uh is that
assault
shining lights on someone is someone
harassment maybe so they're harassing
the guy and he oh
he responded with excessive force maybe
display brandishing a weapon
and he was when he was drunk while he
did it which is another form of crime
they said he appeared to be or he was
intoxicated
no they said he appeared to be him and
and from the from the first part of this
press release it sounds i'll tell you
what i think
i don't know if this guy was drunk i
don't know if he chased somebody with
chainsaw
none of that's on video it sounds like
the police saw a mob of people
and said oh no what do we do and they
said and and then the other cop is like
there's no way we can deal with this mob
well uh what if we arrest the guy in his
house
yeah arrest the guy in the house to
appease the mob we're just talking about
this yeah i talk about a lot
this is uh well that's the case that's
bad policing
although they're keeping bad so their
job is to keep the peace that's like
their main gig that's the cops main
thing and that means
when when the mob comes to your house
you will get arrested not the criminals
so weird now here's the best part
one of the main guys who was live
streaming this one of the most prominent
activists
had previous uh has been according to
some reports
organizing parties at uh alleged racists
homes
they're like going to people's houses
and they're you know staging protests
this is the guy i was talking about
earlier who believes he has a right
at least according to one outlet he has
a right to defend himself
against police physically if they're
unlawfully arresting him
same guy same activist now he was at
another major event
where some some young girls like i think
they were 13 and 15 went missing
and locals in the community started
looking for them
they went to this block where the police
had canvassed and found and the cops
found nothing
the cops said it's not a critical
missing person's case because it's only
been four hours
it's not even been a day so are they
really missing the activists got angry
this guy showed up to a house where
someone claimed to had seen to have seen
the girls
there were about a dozen people already
there and this guy was there as well the
mob started protesting in front of the
house
and then it quickly devolved into chaos
according to one story
two 14 year olds got shot gunshots rang
out
police came in and someone set fire to
the home
the firefighters put the fire out and
left someone set fire again apparently
the firefighters had to come back and
put the fire out again
the home was like like not burned to the
ground
but severely damaged turns out the girls
weren't missing
at all they were just hanging out at a
friend's house so a
mob of crazy people showed up to a house
fired guns shooting two people and
almost burning down a home
igniting it twice for what some fringe
accusation
well that same guy most one of the most
prominent activists in the community
shows up to this dude's house he
probably knows this he lives in
milwaukee
it was it was a national story when this
house got set ablaze
so what what do you do you're in your
home this these same activists show up
the same chance you had heard the
gunshots you heard about the gunshots
the last time it happened people getting
shot
and now they're in front of your house
screaming at you
what do you do i would have called the
cops well that was the guy inside
the cops were apparently there
monitoring it um i still would have
called the cops
um and then maybe grab the gun but if he
was too high to think of that
straight who knows why would you assume
he's high because the cops said so yeah
a bad assumption maybe yeah i would have
called the cops first if there's a mob
assembling outside first thing i would
do is notify police so i'm on their side
the cops are gonna say it's a peaceful
protest and they have a first amendment
right to do so it's a semi-peaceful
it's a mostly peaceful protest they're
they're they're
harassing me through my window and are
they allowed to assemble on my property
yes
they weren't on this property they're in
the street oh well if they're shining
lights on his property then they're on
his property
that's a good point they were shining
lights through his windows and blasting
music at him and screaming and ball
horning at him yeah then they're
infringing on his property
i would say so so it's it's an
interesting dilemma
because maybe he was trying to deter
the people by by branching the weapon
definitely absolutely
but uh i mean maybe he crossed the line
i don't know
what do you think i don't like vigilante
mob justice i think that how do you
police that stuff
because i mean i'm asking uh you send in
swat uh
the riot control police you got to push
them out so
what tear gas batons military like heavy
it's the only way
pretty much right we were talking
earlier about how
the first amendment that was supposed
that was the first article
that would was to become the bill of
rights
talked about how 50 000 people
deserved would get one representative in
congress
the founding fathers did not predict
that we would have 750
000 people for every one congress person
they thought it was going to be 50
000. population growth is massive
so it's really easy to put together laws
based on small population
and constitutional rights and i've
talked about how civil disobedience
is the line where i think we as society
are comfortable meaning like you block a
road
right you inconvenience people nobody
gets hurt you get arrested very quickly
you get a slap on the rest go home but
what happens when you have millions of
people
non-violent civil disobedience can
destroy the country yeah
and so we're entering a point where the
security of the nation is is threatened
because
there's too many people so if you had
you know a small town back in the day
and a tiny percentage showed up to
protest some guy's house be like 10
people
you get a couple shares and deputies to
come out and say everybody go home
you're disturbing the peace
well now you can very easily muster
hundreds of people
and there's only going to be a small
handful of cops available to actually
deal with it
yeah uh especially with social media i
hope you don't mind if i jump in but i
was thinking about this
i think this press release that the
police gave out was designed to keep
more rioting from happening i think them
trying to portray this solo citizen as a
bad guy who had been threatening like
his neighbor with a chainsaw and then
who was clearly intoxicated
like how dare he drink at home on an
evening
and not be prepared for an entire
variety of people to show up
how do you prepare for that if you have
a gun you're armed and you're ready to
defend yourself great
you are also allowed to drink a beer on
a saturday night
i mean it just looks like the police are
out together i think we should modify
the laws so that if you shine lights
into people's houses you're on their
property
i would say that might be the case like
you're you're you're yeah
that's that's a really really a really
good point noise you're if you're
sitting at home wait wait
lydia's points is excellent if you're
sitting at home and you're watching uh
let's say you're watching i don't know
um family guy caddyshack
and you're just like you're just loving
the bill murray the goat groundhog
it's so crazy and you're like i gotta
crack a beer open you crack a beer and
you're drinking
and then all of a sudden a violent mob
starts screaming at your house and
you're like oh man what do i do
so you grab your gun to protect yourself
and they go out look you're drunk
you're under arrest that's not good you
can't defend your home if you were
drinking and hanging out on a saturday
night well they said intoxicated if he
was high on coke you know there's
another
that takes you but they haven't said
yeah yeah yeah
yeah what if what if you still have to
be able to defend yourself i don't care
what state you're in
exactly so what happens if let's let's
let's let's push it a little bit further
what happens if you're in your house and
maybe the chat actually knows this
there uh someone mentioned there are
nuisance laws
yeah but let's say you're in your house
and you're watching you know uh
uh starship troopers three because they
made direct dv versions of it you're a
huge starship trooper's friend you're
like dude
i love this guy you know yeah the
original actors iron sides wasn't he
that yeah i don't know
but imagine you're watching it and
you're and you're slamming down some
you know something like netty light
because you're just like you're old
school
old school low quality of chicago and
you're born and bred
yeah man and you're drunk and then
the most gigantic
super ripped well-known serial murderer
kicks in your door
and he's like i am the great serial
murderer come to kill you
and then you're like uh and you grab
your gun oh but you're drunk
okay i'm exaggerating i'm sure at that
point you're going to be okay
yeah but what if you have a crazy guy
who's very threatening and saying like
you're next where's
where do we draw the line on when you're
allowed to defend yourself if you happen
to have been at home just
having a beer on your own business um if
they're if they're infringing on your
property
ultimately so the lights and the noise
is like
that's hitting me in the ears so you're
here with me i don't care where you're
standing
at that point it's it's it's it's uh it
can be physically damaging if
it's loud enough yeah every blinding if
it's bright enough
that's why they're doing it yeah
absolutely and i i would be curious
about that and so far the chat hasn't
given me anything but i think
i think that is considered a form of
assault if it would be
if it's likely to hurt your ears or your
eyes enough although i do know that the
under the geneva convention that is not
considered like
maiming or just you know disfigurement
but
it's a huge problem and it is like a
lifelong issue laying siege to someone's
home yeah they were doing that in cuba
with sound did you hear those sound
weapons they were using
i remember well i don't know if that was
that was true i think those are
microwave weapons
whoa like melting people's brains with
microwaves his vibration
like really high frequency yeah so this
yeah this that story was crazy that was
uh like
a people where he would hear a noise and
then all sudden they would get
these mental ailments like symptoms with
like loss of vision and headaches and
light sensitivity they had to wear
special glasses because they couldn't
see the light anymore
that's scary stuff dude you start
hearing a weird noise
and then all of a sudden you get
permanent brain damage man and that'll
pass through walls if it's microwaves
yeah yeah with enough power you go
through like dude
stone and why why wouldn't that be like
why would
it's funny how i love spy movies you
know action movies it's like everybody
has a gun with a silencer that goes pew
pew pew
like silencers don't do that but even
beyond that like
why wouldn't they just have like a thing
where they put up against the wall and
then like stick it to the wall and crank
it
and then everyone inside just gets their
brains melted by microwaves i think
that's coming
yeah i think it's here we'll do it from
orbit from orbit yeah wouldn't it like
that cause way more
the waves are to not be direct like i
think you can directly well i guess
infrared laser dude i've been thinking a
lot about modern war and why we never
want to experience it because we don't
know what kind of weapons are coming
from orbit
have you seen we've talked about
laser-induced plasma channels yeah
so the way it works and i am not an
electrical engineer or laser engineer
whatever
but he will be is that an extremely high
powered infrared laser
that flicks on and off real fast
ionizing the air
at the same time supercharges this
massive electrode
so then the electricity travels down the
superheated path
of least least resistance so effectively
they can point the weapon at you and
fire and
strike you with lightning and a friend
of ours jeremy riss who's alien
scientist on youtube you can check out
his channel
uh he has people to help us make one no
he's got it have you seen him have you
seen the videos of the
like the destroyers with the crazy laser
turrets
it's got like three lenses and it aims
and just like it like just locks on and
just holds an infrared laser and the
thing just bursts into flames and
crashes china was testing one and said
we tagged you one of your jets
no that was that was laser targeting oh
so they were just letting us know they
could target the jet
that they were they were locked but i've
heard of what you're talking about
there's a video you can watch it on
youtube
oh and they just take it out of the sky
turn it on turn it off and
did you hear about the ufo over uh the
west coast or whatever um i think
no i just caught reports what's what
happened yeah reports of a weird
triangular shaped flying
vessel aluminum magnetic craft that
they're moving around with the magnetic
no i don't know magnet
i think that's how they're doing like
there's a bunch of really clear pictures
of it yeah
and they were saying yeah how did we go
from like police battalion riots
just like sound weapons sound waves you
just you you were just like i've been
wanting to go there my whole life
man you've just been waiting this whole
time yeah there's a crazy video it's a
crazy video maybe we'll
we'll pull it up tomorrow and uh we can
talk more about about that stuff bottom
of it but uh we we got we got more
antifa stuff all right
two billion dollars in damage look at
this george floyd riots caused
record-setting two billion dollars in
damage new report says
here's why the true cost is even higher
why is the true cost even higher freedom
foundation for economic education oh
they're very cool i like them
when george they say dozens of people
were killed or injured let's get to the
point
they say the u.s has experienced rioting
over racial tensions before but this
report shows the damage from the latest
unrest will far exceed any historical
precedent
the arson vandalism and looting will
result in at least one billion to two
billion dollars of paid insurance claims
axios reports
this will eclipse the record set in the
la 1992 riots
after the acquittal of police officers
who brutalized rodney king
however there are many reasons this
figure vastly underestimates the true
damage wrought by the looting and
violence that has broken out in recent
months
for one the axios report only measures
insured losses
the obvious problem here is that not all
the damage damages were ensured
there was a story i was reading where
apparently
a bunch of these businesses they're
they're haulaway claims
which means like that like for when the
uh the debris in rubble
is capped at 25k oh whereas the actual
cost was 150.
whoa for many of these businesses when
they destroyed the entire building
the insurance didn't cover the cost of
removal of debris wow so they just did
nothing and they walked away from it
so the costs are way higher than two
billion dollars
they want to say as as a previous
explained insurance is no penacia
for the societal ills imposed by rioting
in indeed 75 of us businesses are under
insured
and about 40 percent of small businesses
have no insurance at all
their untold millions in losses don't
show up in the 2 billion
figure so too in so too insurance
doesn't account
for the personal pain and suffering
caused by riding for example
what about the more than 15 people who
died during the unrest it's actually
more than that but some of the deaths
were like peripheral or considered to be
accidental
their lives and their family's pain
don't get counted in any insurance
company's budgetary analysis
nor does the pain of those such as
elderly businessman punched in the face
while his store was ransacked in kenosha
wisconsin manifests itself in total
reports
of an uninsurance compensation you know
what i'm going to say you know they
don't they don't account for
we wait that trump over there can you
you can buy another stand up trump right
yeah i should be able to what about the
painting next to it my mom made
no insurance can't cover that absolutely
no take a picture of it
so what happens when your business
you've got
a painting that a family member made for
you maybe
a family member who died and they burned
it down
insurance can't pay for that right
that's well beyond
monetary costs psychological value is
camp you can't put up money yeah
this is something i was thinking about
because when you burn someone's uh small
business you are
as close to literally in the correct
sense as possible burning the american
dream
because if they started from the ground
up and they've been working on it for 35
years
and they've handed it down through their
family and they've taught all their kids
to work there
that's gone and you cannot buy that back
there's nothing that will replace that i
mean that's more than billions of
dollars like and that's you're just
talking about repairing the actual
structure right about how long it will
take all the lost revenue that your
business isn't open
and uh the people that you'll lose that
have to go get other jobs
yep regular customers who don't shop
shop with you anymore i would love to
know how much
how many of these things weren't how
many businesses that were destroyed were
not insured or were underinsured
most of them and you're saying the sixth
so of the hundred fifty thousand dollars
they only
cover twenty five thousand that's that
was that was a story from uh
the minneapolis uh star tribune i think
it is they said that many of these
businesses
are capped at 25k two billion doesn't
even account for the true cost of all
the damage
man well that's the far left so this
damage
you know you know the to go back to that
sedition stuff with bill barr i think
it's interesting because what if these
people
what if they're pro china some of them
are man you're now you're speaking my
language
i think my conspiracy is that
the chinese go is that the ccp is trying
to sow dissent
in the united states and this is how
they're doing it's a perfect opportunity
did you guys look at that tucker carlson
interview about that girl that chinese
uh
i didn't see it but apparently she said
that it was made in the lab and it was
inten as a weapon
yeah but she also worked at the
university of hong kong okay so that
could be
bunk but right but not out of question
for government to tamper with a foreign
country
so that the point i brought up on that
story for those of us familiar carlson
had on a whistleblower from a university
in hong kong saying the chinese
communist party
manufactured and intentionally released
coven my my thought on that is there's a
potential for bias
because she was working you know in hong
kong so
hong kong is being repressed and
suppressed by the chinese communist
party
and uh but but but but i will say
why do we trust one expert over another
if they have the same credentials
why is it that if one expert comes out
and says it's not man-made we say
you got it done that story is over but
when she comes out everyone says fake
news ignore it
they suspend her on twitter yeah she has
to spend it on twitter
and on instagram tucker carlson's post
was flagged as fake news
here's the best part when it says see
why this is fake
it doesn't actually talk about the
whistleblower it references
months old stories about kovid so
we have a news story we have an actual
researcher
who is working at university in hong
kong saying they know this and they
published a paper on it
and now they're they're taking old
stories that don't actually reference
anything having to do with her
and using it to prove tucker's story is
false well okay
so that's crazy um that's a little
over over managed i think so free
software i'll say it again free software
let's have like a
government free software social network
that you know is run by the people
um but okay so covet aside maybe that
they're tampering
and and funding this chaos or
you know in some capacity trying to make
everything
crazy it's perfect timing i mean they
hate trump they want to make trump look
bad
maybe i don't know this kind of helps
trump in some ways but the economic
damage is bad for this country
devastating yeah and psychological damn
people are like the suicide rate i don't
know what it is but i've heard that it's
gone up
like like sadly yeah sad awful like
forcing them
blessed that we've been able to all live
kind of together in a house
keep our sanity the socialization is key
i cannot imagine what it would be
sometimes i go into these moments like
what if i was living alone in an
apartment in like new york
how horrible the last six months would
you be insane i would have gone nuts
the most gross internet videos is what i
would have been doing
it would be just people would be like
shut up going slowly
negative oh yeah you'd be probably going
out screaming in the streets
i don't know what man you're broke
you're about to be evicted you're angry
who do you blame
the government i would have blamed that
i would have been it's i would have
become radicalized
like in my beliefs because i already
believe that there's a you know
a power structure out there that's
pulling the strings on this system
i'm very red-pilled by the way and i try
and play it off like i'm not
because we need to keep things stable
yeah we try and i would have
lost it i think and yeah and there's so
many people in that position right now
well it is true that uh there was an
intelligence report saying that china
and russia are both interfering
and the official statement was that
russia prefers china i'm sorry
russia prefers trump but china prefers
biden
so pick your poison i i don't think
russia is as bad as they claim no i'm
going after the democratic
republic of russia what's called what i
mean is russia is a
bad place for a lot of reasons but in
terms of being a threat to the united
states it's not nearly as bad as they
they're trying to claim it oh it's not
they're communist anymore
it's not even about that it's about are
they a threat to the u.s china is a
substantial threat to the u.s
and their cyber security their attacks
and
you know yeah they're that we actually
have confrontation with them we have
some confrontation with russia
but i think china's the bigger threat
yeah dude the communist party of china
is some one-party system has control of
their entire
government that's so weird yep the party
yeah so no uh not not not a fan and if i
had to make a choice i'd say i want the
guy who's
opposed to china because china's the
real threat and and i've been i've been
covering a lot of stories pertaining to
china the things they've been doing for
a long time like
russia they're trying russia once set up
a trade federation yeah
in eastern europe oh they're trade
federation putin you know the whole
being in office for 20 years thing it's
it's constitutionally legal in russia as
far as i can tell from what i've learned
and it is he is a hardcore dude like
he's he's this
xkgb like stone cold face killer
machine he looks like you know when you
look at the guy rides a bear in in some
memes
in some memes so yes yes i don't think
that he wants to be
the the controller of rush i think he's
just terrified to let it go and see it
devolve back into that that's that's all
all that's
conjecture no no it's all power
corruption yeah it's better if i'm in
charge you'll see
all of these despots in the in north
africa and the middle east who are like
if i go you'll see how bad it is yeah i
think that's his mindset right now and
then to be honest libya did get really
bad
you know like i would like to see a
peaceful transfer of power
in russia i think i i feel like he's
waiting for a great leader in the united
states to emerge so that he can
breathe easy and let go and make sure
stuff doesn't yeah i don't know
people want power i don't want to give
it up thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8 p.m so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you